[Music]
we've got all the latest d3 deets and
they are totally wicked we're going to
talk about umas new hair carry and gills
new looks and also what is a yawn jar
check out our video to find out a sweet
tradition the director has carried on
since his high school musical days new
to the things get up to the minute
notifications of our newest videos by
hitting the notification button and be
sure to like this video to now check out
the latest d3 deets we discovered watch
until the end to find out an epic plot
point reveal we found uma live on set
this is all hands on deck
Disney just leaked a photo of uma and
her crew in their savage new to send us
three costumes and they did not
disappoint after the release of the
photo China and MacLean was finally able
to go live from the set in a video
showing off her new look we're not
afraid to say it her hair is gorgeous
Chyna showed off her hair pointing to
the cornrows and it looks like uma
traded in her pirate hat for a braided
crown like the sea Queen she is the rest
of her teal blue hair is flowing freely
except for a few long braids with shiny
trinkets at the end when they were
filming d2 director kidney Ortega told
costume designer Khorasan that he wanted
Emma to look like she had been dragged
on the ocean floor cara totally pulled
that look off in a sentence - but in d3
uma looks like she strutted along the
ocean floor and picked out only the
shiniest trinkets and seashell inspired
accessories but she still has a hint of
pirate with those leather bracelets and
rings but added some shiny seashell
mermaid aspects to make her look fierce
and sophisticated hairy hooks new look
is it just us or did Harry hooks look
take a dark and sinister turn with all
the attention Thomas Doherty has had
from dating the descendant start of
Cameron is it possible Harry's going to
have a bigger part in d3 he certainly
looks a lot more wicked than he did in
d2 even his hair looks darker so let's
go over the differences harry wore a lot
of rusty reds and descendants to his
look was more playful and mischievous
but his new look takes chorus ons
scallywag swag looked down a darker path
it looks like harry got in a fight with
a pirate ship and snagged every net and
hook on the way he traded his rusty
leather vest in four am innocent dark
maroon colonial jacket with the sleeves
ripped off
he also surrendered his pirate hat but
he still got his father's hook and looks
like he's full-on Incredible Hulk doubt
of his pants nice high waters dude so
well Harry have a more important
presence in the third movie looking at
him it's easy to tell that's something
wicked this way comes
gills new look it appears that all the
villain kids are looking a bit more
grown-up with a darker edge gills son of
Gaston is no exception
looking at gills new duds reminds us of
a sort of cowboy pirate golds and browns
with the color palette for Gil and his
look has a lot less flashy trinkets and
hoop than uma and Harry Gill looks like
he can lasso a giant sea horse or right
on top of a bucking Beluga and without
all those rings and nets on his outfit
he probably won't get hooked on a
fishing line Gill still has the same
strap that goes over his chest but we
noticed something interesting about his
gloves in d2 gila was rocking some
distressed handyman gloves with the
fingers cut off and they matched in
gills d3 ensemble he is wearing
mismatched gloves one of the clubs
appears to be similar to the distressed
handyman glove from d2 but the other one
is made of dark studded leather it looks
really cool but we started wondering if
Gill losses of the glove and had to wear
mismatched gloves instead either way we
love the look sneeze twins so by this
time most fans know that some new cast
members were added for descendants three
there's Cheyenne Jackson who's playing
god of the underworld from Hercules you
all know who were talking about
it's the blue flames haired bad-boy
Hades who might also be mouths dad that
remains to be unseen then there is dr.
fossil ear and his daughter Celia who
are being played by Jamal Sims and Jada
Murray and then there's the most
adorable addition yet you guessed it
sneeze twin sons squeaky and squirmy
played by Christian Convery and Luke
Roesler now we haven't officially seen
the costumes on any of the newcomers but
some fans just couldn't wait any longer
so they decided to create their own
ideas for what squeaky and squirmy will
look like in the Disney setting the
first fan art we
found pictures squeaky and squirmy in a
rowboat with their dear old dad Smee
Christian Convery reposted the fan art
but the caption that said squeaky loves
it the next piece of fan art features
squeaky and squirmy with uma and her
crew we love those little red hats
we are hoping Disney reveals the new
characters in their costumes soon other
cast members we mentioned the new cast
members who are joining the villian kids
for what promises to be the most epic
descendants movie yet but we wanted to
have a little fun and speculate on the
new characters costumes and looks we all
know what Hades looked like in the
Disney animated classic Hercules in that
film Hades is wearing a long black Greek
toga
it's classed by a skull and it billows
at the bottom like smoke let's face it
the cartoon version is not really
attractive enough to be malice dad he's
got beady yellow eyes sharp pointy teeth
and gray skin this guy needs to see an
orthodontist and dermatologist ASAP we
love the blue claimed hair it's pretty
safe to assume they're keeping that blue
flame tear for Cheyenne Jackson's Hades
but what about the rest
will he be wearing a black toga the
other villain parents didn't stray very
far from their traditional looks so will
Hades do the same and then there's dr.
fossil erm Celia we are hoping that
live-action Celia looks like the Celia
in wicked world because that look is
wicked cool and we can totally see Jamal
Sims in the role of dr. fasoli err fun
fact
Jamal is also the choreographer for
dissonance 3 so there's a good chance we
will get to see all his boss moves in
his own dance number welcome back dude
there is one more character that we are
thrilled to find out is making it come
back in descendents 3 it's our favourite
talking dog dude it looks like dude is
rocking a new look too and it looks very
similar to Carlos's style it's a black
and white leather vest the perfect size
for his canine friend we don't know all
the deets about dudes roll in d3 all we
know for sure is that the descendents 3
Twitter page posted this pic with the
caption welcome back dude what the cast
and crew have to say about d3 def
Cameron went on the Disney descendants
YouTube page to talk to the fans at the
Disney Channel go fan fest she shared
with the fans that she knows
sentence would be nothing without them
she also shared that she can't give away
all the secrets but she can say that
decisions 3 will be bigger and better
than ever before she said there will be
all new music and killer dance
performances from the clips we've seen
with the rehearsals Doug is right this
looks incredible back at the recording
studio
Sophia Carson posted a picture of her
and the crew on Instagram saying she
wishes we could listen to what they just
recorded china anne mcclain also posted
a pic of her in the studio so we can
expect another epic move a song in the
third movie we got a peek at the first
page of descendants three scripts and
while there are no spoilers on it there
is an inspirational message from their
film producer Wendy japhet and director
Kenny Ortega in the message they
welcomed the casting crew and said that
they are prepared to make another
fantastic movie together they added it's
their intention to surpass their beloved
first two descendants movies they thanks
everyone and said they could not do it
without them and they signed off with
long live evil fan theories and
reactions the descendants three Twitter
account posted a major clue about what's
going down in the new film they posted a
picture of Sophia's costume screen tests
with the clapboard and frame on the
clapboard under steam it says Sophia
moto sport then next to that picture
they posted the cast in their new
costumes for the movie they called it
their moto sports books then there's a
pic on Instagram of dub Carmen sitting
on a motorcycle coincidence we think not
so is there going to be some sort of
moto sport action in d3 Mao had that
cute purple scooter in d2 but these
motorcycles would be a major upgrade and
all their outfits would make it a lot
easier for them to hop on a motorcycle
so what do you guys think will they
ditch the limo and purple scooter for
some speedy road rockets or are they
just calling the new look for the cast
the Moto Sport look fans on ullas new
look fans are so excited about the new
look of the villain kids but one man is
totally really feeling himself on
predicting umas new hairstyle
Caleb Cortes 77 posted on Instagram that
he couldn't believe that he was able to
predict her look he showed a picture of
his fan art saying that he got the
little braids on the top of her head
right and that her hair falls smooth
down her shoulders with little golden
details of her braids and of course her
blue eye shadow which was pioneered by
her mom Ursula nice art Caleb you
totally nailed it yandar it's official
Kenny Ortega is bringing back the yandar
if you guys don't know what the yawn jar
is will explain about 13 years ago when
Kenny was directing High School Musical
he invented something called the yawn
jar for every yawn he caught from his
cast and crew he collected the dollar
from them and put it in this jar to
donate to the make-a-wish Foundation at
the end of production Kenny would match
whatever he collected in the jar with
his own contribution and present it to
the foundation
Kenny posted a picture of the yandar
which he's bringing back on set for
descendants 3 he is so proud to help the
children in the make-a-wish Foundation
and she thanked the cast and crew for
all their yawns the Big Sleep
did you guys know that they are calling
the third movie The Big Sleep
now this could have just been their
working title for the movie or it could
have been a clue about a major plot
point here is what we know on the
Canadian website called what's filming
descendants 3 is listed and in
parentheses it says aka The Big Sleep
so they are still using that title while
they are currently filming in Vancouver
we also know that Sleeping Beauty's
daughter Audrey played by Sarah Jeffery
is coming back in d3 and so is Sleeping
Beauty or princess Aurora's mother Queen
Leah
so is this their chance to get even with
Maleficent for sending Aurora into a
long long slumber will ala Varadhan have
a big sleep cast upon them it's hard to
say but with the title like The Big
Sleep it seems obvious that someone is
going nighty night for a while and who
will it be what you guys think of the
new villain kids looks do you think uma
Harry and gills costumes hotel of some
dark and sinister events on the horizon
and what do you make of the Big Sleep
title there's certainly more to come and
we will be keeping you updated on the
regular but for now have an amazeballs
day that's the latest on descendants 3
thanks for checking out our video catch
you next time
on
the things
[Music]